voglio vedere i tuoi amici malati sì ma
come amici in palla in palla in un
sospiro 6 persona a di spiego come
funziona questo gioco questo gioco
funziona che tu perdi
basta mai ciao marco cazzola lessico
sono sei giocare su cazzi tua amica
niente allora maria gioco io zitto sono
primo 6 crea melo sono primo vai vai
così ma davvero non male così via
ma c'è poi la carmen capito il rischio
forme più sciolto a sei società si fa
così santa qua riguarda si fermano ma ci
avrai una famiglia un po scontenta di
averti messo al mondo si muove in
ritardo
vado affiggere are kakà è ok ma io non
ho capito se questa mattina ad una
cooperativa bisogna giocare insieme a
leon lo spinge madama gli ho dato utile
che sarebbe questo che io sono dietro di
te già paper arca sarai stronzone
nell'anno elisa perché hai fatto a 2 la
notte già questo secolo vent'anni e zio
papavero o gesù cristo
basta quasi di cancia mini ti manchi
mandavo alemanno vaticano
cosa vuoi questa non riesce a fare
qualche facilissima non si chiama cosa
non riesce a fare gioco io sono un
problema di questo ok per i medici siano
passare in mezzo volendo no lei ha letto
il bellissimo vinicola questo bellissimo
come devi premere i tasti per
direzionarli ma è bravissimo
no no no no no basta distratto padana
guardia presente perché devo far parte
le cose malizia 9 così visto vai dritto
dopo avere la sintassi statista a
sinistra oddio guardi avanti ma bastava
senso ha dovuto saltare io perché guarda
ok ora è ora dovremo un aperto la porta
si ho aperto la porta vieni qua arrivo
c'è traguardo bene adesso dobbiamo
arrivarci insieme po più con un po anche
a me quando nelle palle gol ricaricarmi
per i casinò scaduto molto bravo
bravo dietro gravissimo che un city
voglio porca eva a carico l'ultimo sotto
la prova di bambini stupidi e insegnanti
l'influenza e ma cosa devo fare per
portare in braccio
como piano bravo e io ho pensato ok ok
come come fatta fail ai che erano stato
veramente non lo so prossimo livello
versus diverso ma no dai potevi essere
mica questo è difficile secondo me
queste difficile abbiamo solo dieci vite
a disposizione dove alla fine del
traguardo mai c'è la fine del percorso
vai no torna qui per me qui no non si
caduto che sei caduto mica se avesse
come sua stessa cosa bastardo e invece e
invece io mi sa che qualcuno che ha
detto basta ma è possibile che due volte
di per daiwa house è lontanissimo si sta
zitto tanto adesso tranquillo che vinci
tu questa è per forza sono arrivato
forse c'è poi come sarà il manga
schifosa dai non c'è poi la presenza in
point che si siano dopo cosa comunque
dopo neferet no non è vero io sono
sempre 5 in tanti amici ha sempre un
vantaggio di lunghi ma smettila
vai vai vai carico carico carico mentre
finale per sfilare verso il finale
no no sono caduti gran bastardo ma
scrivere quello che volevo calciare fine
sono riuscito dice la nota
quello che sta venendo su perdite sono
molto assalto finale non ci credo dei
nubi ci vogliono non ci posso credere
che peccato
voglio credere ok ok ma perché non so
saltare gesù lo zio come 626 bastardo
come mai esser lì grazie avermelo detto
critica a lesbica ma non ci voglio
credere che non ci posso credere
primo set di me ho sbattuto sul martello
come ho fatto non ho mai preso quel
mantello casa sarà x cazzo qui ma
cadendo lotti che ricopre
basta ultimo livello sei pronto a
bassissima che fu una volta ceo
maledizione allora facciamo così
facciamo una tregua non si fanno drag ue
tra uomini e leoni non si fanno patti
tra leoni e uomini e affettive e gli che
ti masturbi per praticamente almeno un
comportamento gravissimo ma c'è un
fastidio questo pezzo entrambi i piedi
quindi alla fine bene di saltare su cosa
che tiene la lama una grazia che ho
detto è prego possiamo avanti di paura
non tanto andavo ci ho messo una
microcar mai ti dico per adesso non si
fanno tra i tabulati pensi di mera bravo
è caduto dal gennaio prossimo
no deliziosa
c'è poi il camino mia sulle palle sulle
pale sono primo mi stai sulle pale amico
mio grazie a ciò la testa della
grandezza di più ma non è non ho capito
non posso perso la maledizione cioè
arrivati to di nuovo ma porca eva a
terra sulle palle poterli no eh sì in
teoria sì no da ci sono quando giorno ci
hai fatto no sto scherzando
maledizione io purtroppo imposto mirati
per la testa ce l'ho fatta non è vero si
è giovata non è vero ha aggiunto che
peccato storia l'incremento gaming ok ma
si può bisogna prendere le galline io
come stracazzo ne posso prendere le
galline con la testa ma sto male ma non
avevo idea ma che gran figata 90
giovannone ci riesco ce la farei mai c'è
un pezzo impossibile sebbene porca vacca
ti sveglia arrivando al check point e
non hai neanche il finale io mica fatto
cacciatore a torino purtroppo isolato a
fine fai così doppio cioè poi capuanova
bene è impossibile non ci arriverò mai
c'è il finale di questo livello
20 impossibile no non è possibile mi ha
ritmi mi arrendo
mi arrendo e si tiene anche tu figlia mi
qualità è veramente impossibile sport di
quella sì finiamo luca basta basta
finiamo un passo livello basta guardare
il tuo amico ho mai fatto di averla
sopra non sono amica alberigo guarda che
comunque no non è vero ma non è
possibile
va bè ragazzi spero che video vi sia
piaciuto saint marc barr e guardate
faccio io poi deve fai vai provarlo
fallo per i non ci arriva e che ichigo
mista uscirà sono quindi game qui che in
quiz chi installa un sos tv di stato
dettato esci dg stare al gioco di merda
ai ragazzi spero che non sia piaciuto
ringrazio pietro per le partecipate a
questo gioco insomma a culo gioco mondo
di pianti piace questo gioco ma porca di
queste ho chiamati e domani cosa invece
diamo il momento mi piace anche a
risolvere come da tradizione sono bravi
si schianti cerchiamo mozioni dei
ragazzi e non so ancora del telecomando
però il lavoro rotto in qualche video
del genere perché mi sa che può
veramente bella ragazza
[Musica]